le président russe vladimir poutine et
son homologue kazakh acas image au
marteau caillet font une longue
conversation téléphonique afin de
discuter de la situation de crise au
kazakhstan ils ont prévu de rester en
contact permanent milan les
manifestations contre la vie chère dans
le pays des dizaines de morts du côté
des manifestants et des policiers ces
derniers qui sont désormais autorisées à
tirer sans avertissement on en parle
tout de suite avec à notre correspondant
à moscou un tracteur
dans cette conversation le président
kazakh a décrit en détail l'évolution de
la situation sur place une situation qui
d'après lui tend à se stabiliser à ce
titre il a remercié les dirigeants des
autres pays qui composent l'organisation
du traité de sécurité collective à
savoir l'arménie la biélorussie le
kirghizstan la russie et le tadjikistan
il a particulièrement salué lahlimi
routine pour l'aide militaire apportée
ces dernières 48 heures une aide
militaire qui a contribué à rétablir
l'ordre dans la capitale kassim jomart
tokayev a estimé qu'il était nécessaire
de tenir prochainement une réunion
conjointe entre les dirigeants des pays
de l'organisation une compétition validé
par vladimir poutine même si à l'heure
actuelle aucune date n'a encore été
retenue à la suite de cette conversation
le président russe a eu au téléphone
d'autres dirigeants des pays membres de
l'organisation régionale afin d'évoquer
le dossier kazakh à noter que l'ancien
président noursoultan nazarbaïev qui a
été écartée ces derniers jours du
conseil de sécurité nationale qui
dirigeait depuis son départ du pouvoir
et bien cet ancien président a appelé la
population à se rassembler autour du
président pour surmonter cette crise et
parallèlement dans le contexte des
émeutes qui ont secoué le pays le
ministère russe des affaires étrangères
organise des vols de rapatriement à
destination des ressortissants russes
depuis almaty la capitale économique du
kazakhstan et c'est dans cette ville que
les émeutes ont été les plus violentes